good afternoon I'm David Thorburn the
director of the MIT communications forum
often in preparing for forums I feel it
necessary to remind our invited speakers
of the forum's central of one of the
forum central missions that and that is
to translate specialized terminology
into a language actually used by human
beings that is to say the forum is
deeply committed to a principle of
rigorous but accessible discourse we
believe as one of our most central
commitments that citizens deserve to
have the highest quality level of
conversation and information about
crucial matters and especially about
things pertaining to emerging
technologies but that that information
that conversation must be conducted in a
way that's accessible fortunately the
speakers at today's forum we're not in
any need of any such of such a reminder
because it is a signature of both of the
work of all three of our panelists of
our moderator Henry Jenkins of yokai
benkler and of Cass Sunstein that their
work belongs in that kind of environment
of what we might call the work of the
serious public intellectual none of
these three distinguished writers and
commentators on contemporary culture
simplify their arguments or dumb them
down but they all speak in a language
that can be understood by literate
citizens who are not specialists and I'm
especially looking forward to today's
forum in part because of that today's
forum is the third in an ongoing series
are on which the MIT communications
forum and the new center for the future
of civic media are collaborating and in
order to this fall we had two of the
first two forums in that series one is
on one defining Civic Media in a kind of
general way in a second on games and
media and today's for
I'm is the third you know you know in a
series that I hope will perhaps not be
endless not be infinite but it will but
it will run I hope for a significant
number of semesters the fourth in our
series of our on civic media will be the
fourth forum in our series will be
offered in two weeks on April 24th in
this same space and the title there is
youth culture and new technologies and I
hope many of you will be able to attend
that or access our discussion in one of
the menu on one of the many platforms on
which form events are now available it
if it falls to me also to do a brief
introductions of our speakers and then
to introduce Ellen Hume the director of
the new center for civic media who will
make some brief welcoming remarks before
the conversation actually gets going but
let me very briefly even though this is
probably not necessary for the majority
of you in the audience who opera no
doubt deeply familiar with the writings
of all three of our panelists but let me
very briefly remind you of their of some
of their distinguished work yokai
benkler is the Berkman professor of
entrepreneurial Legal Studies at Harvard
he's become the co-director of the
Berkman Center for Internet and Society
there and he's the author of the wealth
of networks how social production
transforms markets and freedom Cass
Sunstein is the Karl and Llewellyn
distinguished service professor of
jurisprudence in the law school and in
the department of political science at
the University of Chicago is the author
of uncountable articles and books that
are at a very large number of books most
most recently or fairly recently he's
actually published other books since
republic calm 2 point 0 and info topia
how many minds produce knowledge
Sunstein will be coming into our
neighborhood permanently next year when
he joins the faculty of the harvard law
school in the fall and finally henry
jenkins our moderator i want to add
a brief thanks to Henry for agreeing to
moderate here each of these three
panelists certainly would would would
justify a forum devoted just to their
own work and I'm especially grateful to
all three of them for being willing to
sort of talk together in conversation
this way as many of you in this audience
surely know Henry Jenkins is the
co-director of the comparative Media
Studies program at MIT and the author of
many significant books on media and
culture his most recent book convergence
culture where old and new media collide
now finally I'd like to introduce my
colleague and collaborator Ellen Hume
who has also just joined the this this
year has has joined the media lab as the
research director for the MIT Center for
the future of civic media she's the
founding editor and published publisher
of the New England ethnic newswire and
her work as a print and broadcast
journalist covers more than 30 years and
includes serving as White House and
political correspondent for The Wall
Street Journal in the 1980s from
nineteen eighty eight to nineteen
ninety-three Ellen Hume served as
executive director and senior fellow at
Harvard University's Shorenstein center
on the press politics and public policy
it gives me great pleasure to think that
she's seen the light and has now moved
down the street to MIT Ellen Hume thank
you this is going to be very very brief
because we're very excited to have our
three speakers today but I did want to
welcome you thank you David on behalf of
the Center for future Civic Media which
is a proud collaboration between the
comparative Media Studies program which
Henry Jenkins helped to create and the
media lab and we like to say that we're
all about news nerds and neighborhoods
and we really are i'm taking the plunge
from old media where i used to live into
the world of new media and it's very
exciting and henry was very instrumental
in helping to define the space that we
are researching in and it what our Civic
Media what is civic media well it's
really about any
any tool for communication that enables
people to come together for more civic
engagement so it isn't just about
journalism and today's conversation is
really about that debate about how do we
foster greater democracy and civic
participation and so we are at the
center an incubator for new technologies
and ideas and an intellectual hub for
the field of civic media so we're
delighted to be co-hosting this and take
it away Henry so thanks thanks as thanks
for joining us today and thanks David
for a growing generous introduction you
know as we've been talking about this
panel and I've had reporters wanting to
talk about it there's been great
confusion about which of us is the good
which is the bad in which it was the
ugly I'm reasonably sure I was meant to
be the ugly and we can Duke it out
between the other two on the polar
positions but the problem with the
formulation the good the bad the ugly is
it does a disservice of the nuance and
complexity of both of our speakers this
is not a debate between a utopian and
dystopian it's it's a conversation among
people who've asked some hard questions
i think in BO all of their work about
the world we live in today as a
consequence of digital media and the
impact digital media and the social
structures that grow up around that are
having on the potentials for democracy
so what in pulling together the
questions for the day what I've tried to
do is go back to the key books in this
case Republic calm and infra topia in
the case of Sunstein and wealth of
networks in the case of benkler and pull
out some key ideas that i think are
interestingly juxtaposed against each
other in some cases I think they're
points where the two speakers may agree
i think in other cases their points of
disagreement that may have emerged in
their writing but I'm hoping in doing so
we can drink draw the conversation down
to first principles and really engage in
a serious way what would be the criteria
by which we measure the success or
failure of digital democracy and that's
that's really what I wanted to speak to
to set us off I wanted to read briefly
three short statements that by the three
writers it seemed to set up a set of
criteria by which we could think about
the quality of online democracy
the first is from Cass Sunstein any well
functioning society depends on
relationships of trust and reciprocity
and which people see their fellow
citizens as potential allies willing to
help in deserving to help when help is
needed the second quote also from
Sunstein a well functioning Society of
free expression must have two distinct
requirements first people should be
exposed materials that they would not
have chosen in advance and second many
or most citizens have a range of common
experiences and the third a some a
summary sent a statement from leurs
the wealth of networks the new freedom
holds great practical promise as a
dimension of individual freedom as a
platform for better democratic
participation as a medium to foster a
more critical and self-reflexive culture
and an increasingly information
dependent global economy as a mechanism
to achieve improvements in human
development everywhere so the question I
have to both of the speakers is whether
you agree with each other that these are
criteria by which we should be valuing
free expression the day and then how
we'd great and how you would grade the
current communication space according to
these criteria what current practices
promised to enhance to deter the
achievement of these goals and I don't
know which of you wishes the start but
it listed a heterogeneous batch of goods
including individual freedom I wonder a
bit what he means exactly by that the
book has an elaboration the part that
caught my ear most is a sec
self-reflexive culture by which i
understand yohai to mean a culture
that's capable of self appraisal
self-understanding asking how are we
doing and able maybe to go in better
directions to give the culture or the
Internet in general a grade on that
count that's the one I'd like to isolate
is a little difficult because it's so
diverse but I think I'd give it a
c-minus
if I had to give it a grade that is the
the Babel and the excellence the chaos
and the order the brilliant insight and
the cruelty that are on the internet are
not from the standpoint of
self-government or a self-reflexive
culture what we deserve that so much of
what is on the internet now especially
in the domain of news and democracy is
the opposite of self-reflexive it's
entrenchment of pre-existing views
falsehoods spreading like wildfire
corrected in arenas where the falsehood
never penetrated in the first place c-
is not terrible but in the next
generation maybe we can knock it up a
bit so you already move to a future one
of Henry's question and I and I'm going
to try to pull back here a little bit
and maybe push back on the C minus x by
slowly so I think one of the things that
shows up in these quotes that I have a
feeling we may differ on is the degree
to which the practical constraints on
action or determinative of how we
evaluate the the level of a normative
life lived as a practical
so let me just and primarily here I'll
focus on the a well-functioning system
meets two distinctive requirements but
before that let me just so a well
functioning society depends on a
relationship of trust and reciprocity
etc I completely agree with that my
emphasis is that the way in which the
net by comparison to the mass media
environment generates trust and
reciprocity is through the practice of
pervasive collaboration on many aspects
of life as opposed to through the act of
in acting and performing and
communicating to the public a certain
sense of authority and commonality which
is I think how the mass media at its
best moment was able to do and that's
the difference between trust and
reciprocity has lived experience in
small ways as opposed to trust in
reciprocity has observed as accepted and
observed public performance but I agree
on the on the criterion on the question
of what a system of free expression
requires what strikes me about this
quote is that it has for my taste too
passive of view of citizenship it sees
citizens as sitting there and being
exposed to a flow a good set of
materials it requires a range of common
experiences but it's not about the
capacity to act my own my own effort to
tease out the requirements of a good
public sphere focused more on the idea
of universal intake filtering for
accreditation and relevance salience or
agenda setting and independence from
both government and corporate and so I
think whether you're focused more on the
degree to which freedom of expression is
about participating in the production of
the agenda as opposed to sharing a set
of common perceptions about what
the agenda is effect significantly the
degree to which you find the mass media
not only adequate but affirmative ly
more attractive than the networked
environment or the degree to which you
are willing to give up some of the
coherence in exchange for practical
independence to investigate pursue argue
differ or correct discuss ok good ok the
the c- may have just been a really hard
grader or it may have been taking the
grade again some sort of let's call it a
realistic ideal rather than a historical
comparison so for asking how are we
doing now compared to how we doing in
1975 probably a lot better along enough
dimensions to give a higher grade so if
we're trying to compare the more passive
authority driven non participatory mass
media in which people are recipients of
communication rather than having a
constructive role the current situation
at least for those who have enough
education and training and background
conditions to be participants in
construction much much better so I agree
with you oh hi on that when I say that
two features of a well-functioning a
free system of free expression are and i
do want to underline these unanticipated
unchosen exposures on the one hand and
shared experiences on the other i mean
those as necessary conditions not
sufficient conditions so you could
imagine what one supreme court justice
called a great menace to freedom that is
an inert people you could imagine an
inert population in which people had
lots of unchosen unanticipated exposures
and lots of shared experiences and that
would not be sufficient for a
well-functioning
a free expression but i do want to
insist on those two points by way of
contrast to what seems to me both a
theoretical and empirical hazard in the
current environment which is the sense
that unlimited freedom of choice
understood as a capacity for self
sorting with respect to communications
is the ideal so in geek world among the
people who are real internet enthusiasts
there's something very close to
university of chicago economics
department thinking that is that if you
have freedom of choice and you can your
sovereign over your own options you can
select the options that you like best
then we can declare victory and go home
what I'd like to say a world of
communications a world of freedom of
expression is poorly served and
potentially tragically served by that in
a well functioning system of
communication you don't construct a
daily me which is your communications
cocoon your little information chamber
it's one where you look and you see oh
there's that I didn't know I was
interested in in the topic of genocide
in fact I thought I hated that but now I
see there's something here and it's
getting my attention or I thought I had
no concern at all about the situation in
Turkey but there's something going on
there that I wouldn't have put in my
daily me I wouldn't have chosen and what
I'm saying especially in a heterogeneous
democracy like ours where the capacity
to self sort is risky from the
standpoint of mutual understanding these
two features as passive as they sound
and in some sense are that is the
unanticipated unchosen exposure and the
shared experience they are indispensable
preconditions I'd like to make with one
other point about that that they sound a
little more passive than they are the
active citizenship as its lived in a
well functioning democracy is fueled by
the shared experience and the
unanticipated
exposure that is those who see a story
about something that gets their dander
up or that makes them think Oh a fellow
human being is in trouble that's not
passive recipient of stuff that's what
energizes behavior that's what makes a
democracy often worthy of the name and
when we have shared experiences as for
example on Martin Luther King Day or
July 4th then we see each other as
involved in a common enterprise that
happens during presidential debates also
during the election and that I say
suggests is indispensable not to people
as if they're staring at a screen but
two people at some point to the next
year actually doing something in their
lives that is participatory I'm happy to
follow up on that I think this is the
closest I will ever get to the
University of Chicago Economics
Department power power is is the core
distinguishing feature between what I
see as my position visa vie well power
and constraint and affordance context
partly its power if one treats that as a
more or less self-conscious application
of constraint to and other to structure
them and partly its context if one sees
that as more or less the set of facts
that aren't particularly applied as
directed force I'm not sure I'm willing
to actually defend that distinction for
our purposes here so that's I think what
separates at least my conception of the
difference between freedom and
constrained and between which is always
just relative freedom and so that's why
I I would resist any standard that is
not the range of actual alternatives
that is out there and the range of
patterns of behavior that we observe in
other places
so rather that's it so this is back to
the c- and in 1975 but also to the
question of what is the common
experience and what is the degree of
engagement i think what we're what what
we can't get away from is that the
production of common experiences in the
mass media environment which is the only
one that's really existed in the
contemporary rise of modern democracies
except for the small earlier demo
republics in that context the sharing of
experience was very much located either
in the hands of a government-controlled
agency setting the BBC aside for a
moment which has its own elitist
problems or the the word in herald NSA
newspaper men are people who write on
the back of advertisements or that and
these are different sources of both
power and constraint that don't actually
create an experience that of common
citizen existence that isn't itself
already located within a certain set of
dependencies and and and and elitism so
now we come to what happens with this
perturbation is not a removal of power I
mean when I completely agreed with the
very important caveat which actually
didn't spend much time I didn't
acknowledge in my book not didn't spend
much time on which is the fact that a
greater degree of freedom requires a
certain set of capabilities both in
terms of knowledge and less salient Lee
at least in in in the in the wealthier
economies a simple
simple access to two equipment and
materials and here I think I've
certainly been influenced in the last
year or two by astir harga ties
excellent work on the question of skills
but still what's an elite is an elite
two million people three million people
say 1% of the population what happens if
the reason that our democracy is better
in this regard is that instead of having
a few hundred or at most a few thousand
people with genuine ability to set the
agenda we now have two to three million
people with a substantial wither who can
affect the agenda without can believe
they can affect the agenda without
kidding themselves too badly and they
know another 10 to 20 million people
within one hop who can talk to people
who can reasonably believe that they can
affect the agenda that strikes me is
beginning to be a very large set of the
population that can push on power in
different ways and I think the evidence
that i would suggest for that is the way
in which the netroots have been playing
a role within the Democratic Party far
from control far from complete success
but a very different kind of
responsibility capacity to organize
within the party let's just take one
party in this regard very different a
relative role I guess the the
Connecticut senatorial primary was the
most visible example of that in 2006 the
efforts particularly in my DD to get
contributions true from safe seats from
war chests of safe seats into the
National Committee in order to fight and
improve the fighting abilities in
marginal seats that's a level of citizen
participation in Party politics that was
limited to a much smaller
group that's a form of participation
that's a form of making common cause
that's not fringe crazy groups that's a
much more democratic process where most
of the decisions about where are the the
party and who the nominees are will be
happens and it's that kind of freedom
and that kind of ability to actually say
I can affect this that I find
particularly attractive let's continue
to the second question and I pose to the
speakers which has to do with this we've
already edged toward it this question of
a digital Enclave I should remind some
of you in the audience if many of the
quotes I'm drawing on here or on the
sheet and the first one on the court on
the sheet is the one that I want us to
sort of bounce around for a bit that's
again Cass Sunstein a communication
system granting individuals and
unlimited power to filter threatens to
create excessive fragmentation and I
wondering too long ish quote I had from
from benkler but it's safe to say that
your book takes a very different view of
this this is what you call the the
babble hypothesis and I just thought
it'd be useful for you to to sort of
talk through a little bit the you know
the disagreement that emerges on this
question of are we in danger of
excessive fragmentation or insularity as
a consequence of the new media landscape
I spoke last well since you raised it
and I never I can i dodge that respond
to it I think it's important to
recognize that this isn't a theoretical
claim it's a it's a it's an empirical
prediction are based on a certain set of
plausible theoretical assumptions and I
think what we've seen just in terms of
what little evidence we have and and and
the work is ongoing and and we're
certainly continuing to try to we when I
say we at the Berkman Center through a
couple of our projects trying to as well
as of course many other people in other
places trying to provide better data
about the structure of the public sphere
better data about the questions of how
fragmented the discourse is is there in
fact something like a common agenda if
there is where does it come from is
there a difference between it and the
mass mediated public sphere my own
answer in the book was that my best
interpretation of the present best tools
we have which is link analysis and from
it okay sorry you I'm not sure what I
shouldn't shouldn't explain so Z I'd say
most productive tool of the last seven
years in mapping the shape of discourse
of the net generally of political
discourse in particular has been linked
analysis that is they who links to whom
and in what shaped and what shape does
the network take and I spent a good bit
of time in the book are not creating new
data but interpreting the data that I
had before me by the end of two thousand
five which suggested that what we saw
was not daily me and in this I think
actually a you you agreed on various
levels that daily us is the is where we
are now in some senses with its own
problems but rather than what we have is
a structured public sphere we have more
salient points that are central nodes in
networks we have a fairly shallow
network so that the number of hops
between everyone and a sufficiently
visible site that it might be picked up
if there are other sites that link to it
so when you get down to narrower subject
to more specific groups you actually
begin to see visibility and then things
that are visible that people point to
because they're important within that
community of intense interest begin to
rise higher up and so fragmentation gets
avoided and I'm leaping over the very
first round of link analysis which
suggested that because of the power law
distribution of links on
the net really what we have is a
replication of mass media all of the
eyeballs are in a very very small number
of sites and I think that's an
overstatement instead my somewhat
Goldilocks not too much not too little
just enough to not have too much power
just enough concentration to not have to
match fragmentation it's a little it's a
little bit of wishful thinking but I do
think that it's actually the best
interpretation of the data as we have it
and I think it's more it's something
that we need to continue to observe and
to try to find better tools to look at
but if that's in fact the case that is
to say if the practices of the last
decade have not resulted in the daily me
that was just a that was a prediction
but it turned out not to be the
universal practice but instead we have
things ranging from google news that's
the exact opposite in some sense social
networks that rely on all sorts of
connections between people collaborative
filtering and recommendation systems
that allow people to troll large amounts
of things but throw them together into
sites that have fairly large
concentration clusters of communities of
interest that focus on various subjects
and raise things to a certain salience
such that the most linked sites become
essentially in some sense a transmission
tower for the community rather than the
broadcast to which everybody listens
then again if I return to by comparison
to the baseline is it more fragmented
than the mass media yes is it so in
salutary terms in the sense that now you
can have communities that talk and argue
about substantive issues in ways that
were extremely difficult to find in the
mass media environment yes does it also
mean that there are communities that
obsess about things both trivial and
mean absolutely and that they use these
are more visible to those who don't
participate in them because otherwise
they were simply in the back
also yes so not a utopia but I'm less
worried about fragmentation in this
regard as best we can see given the
practices that have developed this is
great a couple of years ago I was
involved in a study of Boulder Colorado
and Colorado Springs where we wanted to
get people together from Boulder to talk
about climate change and same-sex unions
and people from Colorado Springs to talk
about the same thing not mixing the two
we knew that Boulder was liberal and
that Colorado Springs was conservative
we wanted to make sure we had the types
we wanted so we asked the people in
Boulder what they thought of Vice
President Cheney and if they liked him
we excused them from the experiment in
Colorado Springs if they disliked Vice
President Cheney they were excused we
didn't have to excuse many people the
purpose of the experiment was to have
like-minded people deliberate with one
another on the three issues and to see
what happened to their anonymous pre
deliberation statements of view compared
to their anonymous post deliberation
statements of view and three things
happened the people in Boulder liked an
international agreement to control
greenhouse gases the median person
before they talked together after they
loved an international agreement that we
should sign it yesterday the people in
Colorado Springs didn't much like
affirmative action programs before they
talked after they talked they really
hated affirmative action programs on all
three issues our Colorado Springs people
got more extreme in their anonymous post
deliberation statements of you mind you
and our Boulder people got more extreme
also the second thing that happened was
people got less diverse in Boulder that
on the three issues our Boulder people
were liberal they all disliked Vice
President Cheney but they were
not the same on these three issues
internal diversity in their anonymous
post deliberation statements of you was
squelched after a pretty short period of
discussion on the three issues they came
into line with one another same thing
happened in Colorado Springs as a result
of this the people in Boulder were a
little to my left with people in
Colorado Springs a little to my right
after they talked the gap between them
Lee leapt okay this is a study of Group
polarization which suggests that
like-minded people engaged in
deliberation with one another typically
end up a more extreme point in line with
their pre deliberation tendencies you've
got a group of people who like Senator
McCain and think senator Obama doesn't
really like America very much if they
talk to each other they're going to
think those things big time after a
short period of discussion that's an
empirical claim about the consequences
of deliberation but my central claim
really is not an empirical claim it's a
theoretical claim which is to the extent
that people are using the internet so as
to replicate our Colorado experiment
there's a problem from the Democratic
point of view it has to do with the
preconditions of a well functioning
democracy to the extent that the
internet is operating in this fashion we
have a problem and the notion that
freedom of choice the ability to self
select the ability to produce even your
own information content is a full cure
for what ails us runs into this obstacle
nonetheless Yohai is right to suggest
that some people who are taken with the
theoretical concern also offer an
empirical claim which is the internet is
making things worse or bad from the
standpoint of mixing the boulder people
of the Colorado Springs people and so I
just want to say a few things that
engage the empirical question not fully
we need to have a lot more work on this
and I know some of people here actually
doing that
and with a little luck we'll be able to
sort this out as much better than we can
now here are just a few bits of data for
you the daily cost to which I think
there was an implicit reference a few
moments ago is red guess what percentage
of readers or Republican of the Daily
Kos about 1% of readers of The Daily Kos
a Republican Pew did a study a few years
ago which was widely taken as a
vindication of the non echo chamber
effect of the Internet twenty-nine
percent nearly a third of people in the
pew study knew the argument supporting
their Canada and undermining the ponies
in Canada had no clue about the other
side of the argument 22 but nearly a
third knew everything good about their
account everything bad about the
opponent had no idea we're clueless
about the arguments that political
opponents had on behalf of their person
and the other side that one-third
worries me fully twenty five percent a
quarter of participants in the Pew study
candidly acknowledged to an experimenter
we like reading material that just
supports what we already think we don't
like reading material that goes the
other way that's one quarter of Internet
users who said that as their hargett I
very good empiricist interested in the
operation of the internet did a study
not long ago of the blogosphere in which
he she observed linking practices which
suggested as a first approximation that
conservatives link overwhelmingly to
fellow conservatives liberals do the
same thing the principal qualification
is a non-trivial percentage of
cross-linking she observed but of that
cross-linking a plurality of the links
were to cast contempt and ridicule on
the other side in which the liberal
crosslinkers worse aching holding the
Conservatives up like a bug and saying
look how ridiculous they are look what
the sorts of things they say that
doesn't suggest well-functioning
networked public sphere a similar study
of the blogosphere
looking at the a-list conservative and
liberal blogs found basically the same
pattern if we want an authoritative
account I'll give you what strikes me as
an authoritative account of the
empirical hypothesis which I don't
endorse I worry over this to the extent
that is occurring a superb study said
the following sites cluster in
particular topically and interest
related sites link much more heavily to
each other than to other sites
individuals cluster along around topical
organization or other common features
like minded people quote read each other
and quote each other much more than the
other side that's your high benkler
brilliant it's a few things one Rush
Limbaugh so to the extent that we worry
about polarization and fragmentation
it's not obvious that we need to worry
about the net and since I continue to
think that we need to compare that in
order to diagnose three steps back how
should we feel about the net as a
platform for the public sphere well by
comparison to what why does it matter by
comparison to what because on the table
there are always practical questions of
design of legislation of emphasis in
political campaigns and in and in
ambition for for design and so the
question always come to me the question
always comes in the trade-off between
these two models and so the degree to
which the net is particularly polarizing
as opposed to that between
talk radio and fox news we have fairly
powerful example of a quite polarized
insular media and the question then
becomes what is the arc of culture that
brings us to the kind of polarization
that we saw with basically i'd say
probably the 94 election as a moment of
significant polarization at least within
the mainstream as opposed to really
fringe groups I certainly it can't be
the net and so that would that would
that suggests to me that there are
alternative cultural models and that
when we're trying to identify just for
American political culture what happened
given the phenomenon that we've seen in
mass media I'm not sure that I'm
convinced now the question of the of the
of how we interpret the data if I
remember correctly hargett I also did a
Content analysis of these sites and
didn't find polarization as she compared
the kind as she tried to score the kind
of positions over time but I it's been a
while since i'd since i read that i may
be wrong but that's my my recollection
was that it was an ambivalent set of
findings there was highly differentiated
just like in the earlier study but still
substantial cross over there was
pointing out haha there was also a
statement that yeah actually you don't
see a from a Content analysis which is
has its own limitations polarization but
but i'm not i'm not sure i remember that
correctly but it's worthwhile looking so
the baseline relative to mass media we
see this happening in mass media and the
question is whether we're seeing an
overall a cultural phenomenon that's
rate that's layered over the fact that
you do have
again if I have maybe I have a weird
life may but but I think of how we are
in our conversations when we talk
politics or for that matter when we
don't talk politics politics is
sometimes hard we hang out with friends
if we know that their views are on the
other side often we might skirt issues
and spend more of the time talking in
the most discursive of spheres face to
face talking with people with whom we
agree occasionally we'll have a real
argument will have someone that strikes
me as a plausible description of how we
are even in the best of coffeehouses and
so that's not inconsistent to me with
the pattern that we're seeing large
which I completely agree with the person
you quoted which is that we largely
cluster and talk most of the time with
each other we refine our positions we
tell each other how great we are and how
right we are how wrong they are that's
part of how we build solidarity and
that's how part of how we mobilize as a
party an occasional you can also listen
to the other side and that strikes me as
a plausible description of how we've
always been and as a plausible
description that given a platform with
sufficient degrees of freedom we
continue to be are we going to get from
any kind of platform that is not
authoritarian some overarching the
liberty of civic virtue it's been a long
time since you wrote about mechanism in
civic virtue but that's you too I'm not
convinced I think we're too varies too
varied too ornery decent to get to that
this is this is pretty good Jane Jacobs
wrote a book a long time ago probably
one of the great books of the 20th or
any other century about American cities
and what she observes is the the sheer
serendipity of them
so she says in a city you're walking
along some street and you see a person
or an interaction or a building that
just stuns you it may be beautiful it
might be ugly but it's just so foreign
to your pre-existing experience so what
she says about the great American cities
is that on a day if you're really
looking the fertility and and surprise
of that will alter you alter what you're
interested in alter what you care about
your aesthetic sense maybe even your
political sense so jane jacobs i'll
acknowledge here and now recently
deceased is the inspiration for my work
on these issues the thought I think that
underlies her account of cities is
whatever human nature is it's a product
of architecture so that the notion of
self insulation so that what you see is
a comfort and conforms to what you
thought you liked that's architected and
the great American cities architect
otherwise there's a nice empirical point
that supports what Yohai says which is
if people find another human being who
agrees with them they tend to rate that
other person as smarter and more likable
than they did before the agreement
that's not amazing what's a little bit
amazing maybe is if people find another
person who agrees with them they the
person who are making the evaluation
subsequently find themselves more
competent and smarter and more likable
than they did before and that suggests
there's there is a kind of hard wiring
to the clustering that
that yo hi speaking of but but how much
of it we get depends in a sense on what
are our norms are and our architecture
is you can imagine can to a society in
which the people who are self sorting
Boulder style or daily cause style or
Fox News style a little embarrassed
about it and think well in a society
like ours this isn't what I'm supposed
to do at least not all the time there
can be a norm to that effect just like
we live with lots and lots of norms that
in that counteract aspects of human
nature that are pretty hard hard wired
and if our conception of citizenship on
the internet or elsewhere fits with this
anti echo chamber norm that has an
effect also the internet like a city has
an architecture to it those who produce
websites are responsible for a kind of
architecture they can do it one way or
they can do it another way and my only
suggestion I guess is whatever
hardwiring there may be many human
beings love serendipity and whether we
love serendipity depends on how much of
it we've had and what are our norms are
this is a role point that seven months
ago I moved from Greenwich Village here
so I think I tried to forget about that
youtube you compare the kind of visual
humanity that we were exposed to uh
since it was available in in in in
stored form and the insane variety
quirkiness delightfulness discussed that
you can stumble across that's what I
mean and it happens everywhere the
opinions you decide on the opinions you
like the even though can you believe
this email with a link to the other to
the other side politically even that
kind of link is
part of that link that you described
which wasn't there when the architecture
had to go through the editor yeah it's a
great point and i feel kind of seventy
percent in agreement with you but on
youtube youtube you can understand as an
example of vacation of a great American
city taken in the aggregate that is in a
sense what YouTube is it's got
everything on the other hand what I'd
like to know empirically is how many
people who hate let's say senator Obama
are looking over and over again at that
Reverend Wright video and showing it all
to their like-minded friends how many
people who despise John McCain are
looking at that parody of the yes we can
don't ask how I know about that someone
told me but the parody that makes him
look really ridiculous and seen Island
we call that research ah well well what
and it's ingenious but the constitutive
the concern the concern is the cholera
Colorado ization let's call it of
YouTube this is an empirical hypothesis
in which I have not much confidence but
the empirical hypothesis is if we look
at the patterns of usage of YouTube in
the political domain we might see a
replication of the Colorado Boulder
difference where the people are going on
to YouTube to see stuff that reinforces
their own pre-existing judgments there's
a nice empirical project there and I
hope it's not going to come out the way
I fear okay so let's move from YouTube
to Wikipedia which is another phenomenon
of the digital age that you've both
written about at the bottom of the car
there two quotes I'm not going to read
them which reflect your two statements
about Wikipedia and I wonder if you
could tease out for us a little bit what
how you see Wikipedia what you see it is
telling us about the nature of civil
society about collective intelligence
and about the collaborative production
of knowledge I love Wikipedia for so
many reasons the
the fact that participation while not
quite as huge as as is sometimes
portrayed it's it is amazing that so
many people how many people here have
edited Wikipedia Wow well that shows you
something very large percentage looks
like maybe three quarters have edited
Wikipedia that's fantastic and the fact
is that Wikipedia editing occurs not
just among the elites it comes occurs
among people who know something about
anything at all so Wikipedia Jimmy Wales
the founder of wikipedia said you can't
understand Wikipedia without
understanding at his conception at least
without understanding Hayek a Nobel
Prize winner it's true taught at the
University of Chicago who whose greatest
essay is about the dispersed nature of
information and society that each of us
has bits of information that no one else
in the world has and a market at high x
view is able to aggregate that in the
price wikipedia isn't a price but it has
this information aggregating feature
which is fabulous so the Buicks effect
of participation amazing the existence
of self-correction that is extremely
wonderful also really great the greatest
of all is the is the aspiration which is
coming to be realized by which any
person in the world can get a fantastic
free encyclopedia that conveys a
tremendous amount of information about
among other things health so it's
probably saving live so all that is is
fabulous for Wikipedia to work there
have to be norms in play that prevent it
from being destroyed and if you look at
history under many living persons you
will see cruelty falsehood invasion of
privacy and destructiveness the norms
and the organization are sufficiently
strong
to prevent the lies and the cruelties
from destroying the enterprise but
that's partly just because there's a
hierarchical structure on top of the
collaboration that provides a safeguard
so this doesn't seem to be much of a
point of disagreement I'm so that's
never prevented me from talking
wikipedia is um extremely interesting
partly because at least in the first few
years it started out as almost purely
norms based as long as it was largely
irrelevant to people who weren't
participating in it or rather as long as
it was largely irrelevant culturally so
they're only people who participated
cared it didn't have a problem then it's
got this this problem of becoming
culturally salient and having to both
have some kind of perimeter defense as
well as internal structure I take a
little issue with calling it hierarchy
because I think a Wikipedia governance
is a fairly democratic and participatory
federalized in some sense or around
articles and issues of interest through
people of who volunteer for particular
groups with a very strong norm of
consensus or at least a wide agreement
with an effort to minimize technical
control to the bare minimum necessary
when when issues really flare up what I
find fascinating about Wikipedia is
precisely the fact that it's so fabulous
despite the fact that it's imperfect
which makes it a muddle for the more
general question that I think we need to
ask about human cooperation human
collaboration which is it's feasible
it's feasible in ways that
at the University of Chicago Economics
Department with the inconceivable
because if you were to stand up in 2001
in in February of 2001 when Jimmy Wales
put on 900 stubs on a platform that
invited anyone to do whatever they
wanted with it paid no one to do
anything that's not true paid one person
who ended up leaving because you thought
it was not professional enough and say
that fort for of less than five years
later nature would come to the
conclusion that the result was no not
significantly crappier than Britannica
but both of them were not ideal you
would have been laughed out of the room
and so as an existence proof as and yet
it moves to drive us to begin to
understand that we need a new model of
human cooperation a new model of
understanding human behavior and human
action that builds all of these things
that build the imperfections that
doesn't imagine a utopian altruism but
understands that people are different
from each other that some people are
more generous under some conditions that
some people have more as you called it
trust and reciprocity and other people
have more of a sense of commitment to
collective to collective goods into
doing something well and that building
the platform exactly the point of
architecture both the physical
architecture the norms the whole
environment constructing the environment
that's a major study question that
wikipedia opens because it gives us a
certain mirror not a perfect mirror but
a mirror about ourselves that is vastly
different than the mirror that's been
dominant for so many years through the
model of selfish rationality and that is
limited in different ways than the one I
think your work from behavioral or
economics focuses on
which is much more on the cognitive
deviations rather than on the practices
of cooperation which is certainly what
I'm working on now more than on anything
else so that's this is a very rich topic
so a couple of points about this do you
remember the desktop about John
Seigenthaler whose Wikipedia entry was
vandalized to say that he was rumored to
have been volved in the assassination of
both Kennedys nothing was ever proved
this is maybe very slightly funny in its
absurdity not to him and it was he
worked with the Kennedys knew them well
and this was a libel and it was repeated
his site was vandalized it's had
horrible unbelievable things have
repeatedly been said it's had to be shut
down now that's a very vivid example the
Seigenthaler example of Wikipedia gone
wrong but a sad fact is that the number
of living persons who have been subject
at one or another moment to similar
vandal vandals is very very high whether
the the thing is up there for a day or a
week or three months matters but for
something false or invasive or libelous
to be up there even for a day that can
inflict really serious damage on someone
and the Encyclopedia Britannica doesn't
have that so in our celebrations of
Wikipedia and collaborative production
of which this is maybe the leading
example it's important not to neglect
some some genuine horror usually it's
there for a short time that Wikipedia
produces the reason it's generally for a
short time there are these people who
you know if you look at it and look at
this three you can see they have funny
names they're all anonymous who are who
police now when I say hierarchical I
don't mean like a kingdom or anything
but they have a status beyond that that
most of the people in the room here are
there people here are Wikipedia
administrators you shouldn't identify
yourself i guess because you might get I
don't know someone might be mad at you
oh but I bet I wouldn't be surprised if
there's a wikipedia administrator here
bless you the Wikipedia administrators
are not only to some extent higher and
higher our gate though it is does have
this democratic qualities of the word
baby the wrong one they have these norms
that are amazing norms my favorite of
which involving biographies of living
persons is a norm of dignity which is
widely shared which has is thought to
have a bunch of corollaries so if you
say things about people which are true
but but in the cast and dignity on them
they're really not supposed to be there
and if you say things about people that
are private facts unless they're really
famous people that's inconsistent with
dignity so too if you give undue
emphasis to some aspect of someone's
life which is an indignity even if it's
true and worthy of statement at
encyclopedia that's police also so the
elaboration through in part through
collaborative development of a social
norm of dignity that is to me one of the
very most interesting things about
Wikipedia and it shows something I think
about what's gone wrong in many places
on the internet which have nothing like
that maybe the opposite and it points
towards some potential development in a
way that could be helpful for the future
okay so I'm going to just a minute turn
to the floor for questions I'm going to
ask the panelist one more question for a
quick round of response and let people
start to their people are going to walk
around with Mike so if you flag them
will have some questions lined up by the
time we
we get through this next round around
the questions so the question I want to
ask builds on the exchange you just had
has to do with models of citizenship and
motivations for participation and skills
for participation which seemed to me
grows out of what we've just described
you were talking about the model of
motivation for Wikipedia being different
from an economic model you know both of
you had a lot to say about what a good
citizen is in this world in this new
digital environment and I'm wondering if
you could talk a little bit about what
motivates it what the skills are and
where we're acquiring them what are the
educational implications of all of this
so they're all short you said there are
a lot of there are a lot of questions
there I think the model of citizenship
that I see and hear i'm projecting what
i want not what I have proof for or what
I have even evidence for proof we have a
proof I think it's at least plausible
that if you think you can affect the
agenda you walk through the world with
different eyes and different ears you
walk through the world looking for or
not if not looking at least observing in
ways that structure what you see as
arguments rather than as complaints to
people who are similarly disabled as you
from doing anything and it's a big
difference thinking of it as a good
subject for kibet seeing and thinking of
it as a good subject for commentary and
so ideally we cultivate within ourselves
through the habit of potentially being
relevant as I said the two or three
million people who can reasonably
imagine themselves having some ability
to affect the agenda that's for me a
significant change in citizenship from
the idea that what you're sitting is
sitting in front of a TV and at best
you're able to curse
and say can you believe so that's on one
how are they being acquired practice
practice practice which is to say one of
the things people talk in some of the
studies about young people's use of
media has not being political and I'd
say what do kids do they play and what
do they do when they play they practice
the things that they end up being adults
at the fact that the play is about
something else doesn't mean that it's
not basically the acquisition of skills
and so when I see a generation of people
growing up deeply embedded in
communications and looking for things
and it doesn't matter the resources they
can be looking for maybe dragon eggs
that doesn't matter it's the attitude of
seeking and being able to find and then
use that I think is foundational and
that also goes to the question of
education because I think in this regard
if we use an eye on by no stretch of the
imagination an expert on on on education
but if we begin to use the affordances
of the technology that allow a
tremendous amount of freedom to act in
the world in ways that are meaningful to
begin to bring into the classroom
meaningful projects so that you can act
in the world in ways that teach you how
to seek information teach you how to
create networks teach you how to act and
doing learning by doing not doing not
doing in a form of simply play but doing
in a form that it's a much more
ambiguous and permeable boundary between
the real world and things I care about
and things I do in the classroom that
strikes me as a very important path to
teach both the technical skills and the
attitudes but I think we can't be
sanguine about the the in this regard
it's much harder for me to be sanguine
about the distributional effects and the
degree to which we do or don't have an
education system that is able to have
teachers and to have institutions that
have that attitude of here's a machine
go do something interesting as opposed
to here's a machine be careful you won't
get hurt and that's part of our general
culture of risk again and I'm right what
kids the assumptions about what kids
were able to do at age 9 and 10 30 years
ago as opposed to what would count as
abusive parenting today we're very risk
averse and that's true about the net and
we worry about the net and and and I
completely sympathize with the fact that
there is pain are in this free just as
there is pain in living in the city and
there is risk in living in the city and
there are higher levels of pain airing
it we wouldn't give up on it and we
would embrace its its its its beauty
that's that's where I see the this is a
really large question isn't it the first
and maybe only thing I'd add to what
seemed to me to be excellent remarks
just then is the value of distinguishing
between consumers and citizens so that
along a certain access access as
consumers we need to know stuff we are
active participants in selecting what we
want we aren't it is to be hoped mere
passive recipients of information maybe
we say something about the television
and how it broke down quickly and if
people can see that and so along most of
the axes I think on which yohai spoke
the distinction between the citizen the
consumer didn't matter but we might
think for democratic purposes the norms
that accompany the role of the consumer
are really different from the norms that
accompany the role of the citizen in
citizen you do is a citizen you
shouldn't think when you're thinking
about the Endangered Species Act or
health care
or climate change what's best for me
which is perfectly appropriate for you
as a consumer you supposed to engage in
some process of reflectiveness about
what's what's best that's not what's
best for me and some celebrations of the
Internet in it's still early years seem
to elide the question of consumer
behavior with the question of citizen
behavior and I fear that Google which
like everyone else I love is a culprit
here where it really doesn't unpack
these these things we need a footnote
which is learned hand a federal judge
with a really weird name learn at hand
sad during World War 2 the spirit of
Liberty is that spirit that is not too
sure that it is right and this is for
consumer behavior that is an irrelevant
statement it can be really sure this is
the car you want but in the political
process the hand probably points in a
good direction so for citizens the
preconditions what educational
institutions might do more with than
they do what norms might support is
something like a principle of charity
where we assume most of the time unless
we have really good counter evidence
that those who are in disagreement with
us are well motivated that they are
operating as best they can given the
information that they have and in the
end it's possible that they their
conclusions are the right ones ok we
have questions out there a whole bunch
so I leave it to our mics to pick where
you start we have to wait till late can
you hear me now I just wondering how
much do you think the tools that allow
us to exchange information affect the
disc kind of discourse and you imagine
that new tools in the future will change
the hardwiring the way people exchange
information in the way they the
decisions and perceptions that they
exchange do you mean by changing the
hardwiring like neuro surgeons
polarization yeah yeah well I guess I
think that with the people are hard
wired in two different ways first is
they like to cluster alabang like-minded
others second they we are curious and
one of the things that's very easy to
trigger by the way is is curiosity and
once it's triggered it's almost it's
very hard to resist staying attentive
once your curiosity has been triggered
so that's how hardwired to I guess I
think that one virtue of the internet
it's is its potential to work against
clustering and in favor of curiosity and
whether that so depends a lot on
education really large so the norms by
which we self-govern determine whether
the clustering tendency or the curiosity
tendency gets get strengthened I mean
the basic question though that I that
I'd like to push back on a little bit is
the degree to which how much of us is
hardwired the curiosity for sure some
sense of human affinity clustering for
sure um
but the basic question of the of the
relationship between the tools we adopt
because it's not just about the tools
that are theoretically or even practical
of available but the ones we adopt and
what we have some baseline proclivity to
adopt versus the way in which by using
tools we change the perfect ability of
humans not in the sense of becoming
perfect problem sense of changing and
adapting to a new set of key of
affordances and constraints I think
we're also a very plastic not perfectly
plastic but plastic and perfectible and
there's no independent technology
developed this way and suddenly oops
there's a new choice and we change but
we're in constant conversation between
what we adopt what we want what how and
it's not just about hardwiring in here
and a set of tools it's very heavily
within culture of what we count and
stories we tell ourselves about it I
just have a more fluid story about the
relationship between all of these things
but that all things considered we come
with something we're not nil and that
then we live and change through a series
of affordances of constraints of
whatever set of systems we live through
I think is true hi um I've been taking
part in a seminar by Professor benkler
and we're studying cooperation and
basically what happens in the seminar is
that graduate students present cases of
supposed cooperation many online and
professor banker watches and he nods and
he comments but I don't really know what
he thinks about the content of the
seminar what he's learned so the to the
extent that you feel comfortable you'd
like to share what the seminar has
you've learned how it's changed your
questions have you have new questions
that's something that we interesting to
me
hey let me let me let me just report
that no one is registered it is in the
course it's just two hours where we show
up in a room and people talk about what
they're doing but it's every week and
it's from I know four or five six
departments it's very cool I learn every
week um what have we been doing we've
been looking at some experimental work
on cooperation particularly in this
regard work that came out so just if we
just look at the last couple of weeks we
had somebody prepared present a paper
that they had published with their
advisor in nature a couple of weeks ago
on the relative importance or in this
case perhaps surprising negative
implications of using punishment in
public goods games very interesting
paper and going into this question of
how much so punishment was for a while
thought to be the cynic one on of
successful cooperation in public goods
because there are some people who defect
but then it turns out that it's not the
case so we start thinking about that
there was another paper we talked about
that had to do with actually the fact
that there is a surprisingly larger
amount of cultural variation even within
industrialized countries in the outcomes
of these games than before so some of
the work is is is that kind of work we
had somebody else present work from
actually from from AI from from from
computer science on experiments running
with people collaboration in task
oriented environment as opposed in game
theoretic environments where you
actually set up a task environment and
see what sort of manipulations lead the
Greater and Lesser
collaboration the case studies you were
talking about this is a whole bunch of
things looking at among other things for
example daily costs not as a political
mobilization platform but simply as the
fact of 160,000 people having to come up
with something that would be a
discursive platform if not externally at
least internally how you get people to
collect how you so you've got people who
look for Diaries and put them up you've
got people commenting you put people
commenting on the people who are
commenting and deciding whether they're
fair or not a whole set of structures of
internal at least filtering to make the
internal conversation non chaotic which
is a very interesting structure of
collaboration we oh yes last week it was
somebody presenting on couchsurfing
which is about 450,000 people sharing
about 370,000 couches around the world
where by basically I show up in a city
and I crash on your couch and we hang
out a little bit and there are issues of
trust perhaps and security but it's a
very interesting but it's a very
interesting phenomenon what we try to do
in all of these is see whether we can
begin to abstract a general approach
toward the odds beginning to answer this
question that I was suggesting earlier
of what goes in to making collaboration
successful when you are in situations
that are not quite as abstract and thin
as or no I'm sorry there are not quite
as thick and engaged as traditional
communities where we've seen a lot of
studies of long-standing irrigation
districts heavily social norm based
relations between neighbors but in
something that's much more abstract and
minimal either an experimental setting
or online weather where the connection
is fairly minimal and people nonetheless
communicate but it's a it's a it's an
example of intrinsically motivated
behavior it's not a course there's no
credit nobody's registered it's a lot of
fun
this is a question of unexpected the
results I have the sense when you're
talking about a shared communities as
they grow when wonders if the very very
mechanism of that happening is likely to
produce more of a surface and mechanisms
for communication and a less deep kind
of communication just just because of
the nature of scale of communication
well it's how it sounds right that if
you have a society with 300 million
people even with new technologies it's
unlikely that many are going to be
speaking deeply with many often the only
idea is that even in a society that's
very large it's really good if some of
the time there are communications
experiences that are widely shared
rather than sharply divided it's
disturbing isn't it if there are
narratives about social events that are
radically different from one group to
another and they never meet so one value
of a presidential debate an election the
Olympics a national holiday the Internet
surely can be used for these purposes
even among large numbers of people
there's an unexploited possibility here
that there can be some shared
experiences which give people a sense
that they're involved in a common
enterprise so what you say is clearly
correct and important it helps explain
federalism and many other institutions
that are part of our society but but a
society that's very large had better
have partly just by virtue of its size
the need is greater for a degree of of
common experiences
both of you have spoken about the
phenomenal success of Wikipedia however
other wikimedia projects have not been
nearly as successful as Wikipedia in
particular I've been very interested in
tracking wikinews and wondering why
wikinews has not been so successful what
do you think it is about collaborative
news reporting that's different some
people have blamed their adoption of the
neutral point of view doctrine that
Wikipedia uses as part of the reason why
wikinews is not as successful but I was
wondering what your take on that issue
was well the main reaction is that
lostpedia is really great do all know
lostpedia you know the television show
Lost surely yes no well if you do then I
suggest you consult lostpedia which is a
phenomenal exercise in collaborative
production it's this is too silly is the
soft point I think it might be on point
a little bit because it suggests it
gives us another data point into the
circumstances where a collaborative
production will work why lostpedia's
highly specialized there are other
examples that people have an intense
interest in enough people have an
intense interest both in production and
output there's a community of people who
have good norms and intense interest
with with wikinews one question I guess
is what niche is it fulfilling the
Internet can be understood as an
aggregated mechanism by which you can
find a ton of news so I guess my first
question is why would people want to
participate in wiki wiki news when
there's so much out there that serves
hot overlapping function wikipedia and
my silly example lostpedia there's
nothing like that
so to trigger the norms of cooperation
people have to think I think that
they're giving something to people and
people like that with wikinews do they
feel that way or does it seem a bit of a
waste that's I know just a tiny bit
about wicking is but that's that would
be my question yeah I haven't studied
wikinews but i would agree first of all
the time cycle for news is different the
time for working things out and and the
necessity of the level of mobilization
in a given time frame is higher and so
it places a greater pressure which
requires a higher degree of motivation
but given that there are other outlets
for motivated news reporting that is
opinionated you really need a sub
cluster of people who are particularly
passionate about the idea of objective
news reporting that is not professional
and commercially provided i think that
that just may not tap relative to the
feasibility of more opinionated a mutual
news information gathering pick up on
this notion of objective verses and the
neutrality rule that wikinews has which
is i think part of the problem there and
it goes to some of the earlier comments
about whether we have a sort of
consensual space or a highly the
potential for a highly pleura polarized
space if I think of the news media in
countries other than the u.s. here we
have a notion of objective news coverage
but a lot of European countries for
example the notion of a partisan view is
is alive and well there's a partisan
press I was in London the day the war
broke out and one of the tabloids was
shock and awe with a nice color picture
of Iraq's skyline illuminated by bombs
another was shocking the other tabloid
was shocking and awful with a dead child
on the street so two very different
takes on the same event and that sort of
followed in the course of the week
what's interesting though is the larger
environmental issue that in the United
ates we have a political culture that
quickly is reduced to democratic
republican with us or against us i mean
that binary opposition in some ways is
an environmental condition that in
cultures without it and cultures with
parliamentary systems with multiple
parties i mean the dutch system i'm very
familiar with and 36 parties 36 colors
and flavors and points of view forces
people in some ways to relativize all
the time forces people to make alliances
forces people to accept and accommodate
other points of view so i guess my
question is are there what are the
longer term implications do you think or
should there be longer term implications
and how we organize ourselves
politically is this binary opposition
between two parties winner-take-all and
all that sort of stuff is that is that
where this highly pluralistic
environment that we can now express
ourselves in is that really the the form
that's most conducive to us continuing
to prosper well I guess there's a large
question of political organization there
I guess the part I'm stuck on is the
notion that the fact that we have a bye
party system the two-party system with
Democrats and Republicans necessarily
ensures a high degree of polarization
and us versus them or if not necessarily
strongly inclines people toward that I
don't agree with that I think you could
imagine a possible world of 12 parties
in which sure there's mutual interaction
in order to form a government say or to
create workable coalition's but where of
the 12 11 think we're the right one and
everyone else is confused or terrible so
to you could imagine and at times in our
history this has been the reality a
two-party system in which the Democrats
think well we're a bit better than the
Republicans but some of them are better
than some of us and and vice versa so I
think I think that you're right to say
there are advantages as well as
disadvantages in a multi-party system
winner-take-all has problems but I don't
agree that the forms of polarization
that we're both concerned about map
suggests that ours is inferior to theirs
that there are other things going on in
the intensity of the identification of
us versus them I mean I I certainly grew
up in Israel where there are 20 some as
opposed to 12 each one of which has got
on its each one of which knows exactly
what's right and the other is doesn't I
would actually say that what by what the
two-party system here is done has
eliminated the left and the right and
largely left the middle so so if
anything the u.s. is in a position for
anybody on either one of the parties to
reach to a large chunk in the other
because everybody is so close to the
center by comparison to the range of
what there is in terms of of left which
doesn't really exist as a politically
viable option in the US and serious
fascist efforts that also don't okay
well ah sorry I shouldn't have said that
I didn't end that this is a serious
comment yeah I think actually if
anything the bike part the the two-party
system squishes the practical range of
politically feasible a program and in
that regard makes it easy rather than
the potential for greater polarization
but this
okay okay um I guess I want to speak
briefly and ask a little bit of question
in in favor of polarization in favor of
cluster ization because I haven't heard
that from anybody I mean I think ah
you'll have an clear spoke a little bit
about this idea of you know of expanding
power in the citizenry and i think that
the vast majority of people are
extremely non deluded about the small
amount of power that they actually have
and that the only way to maybe leverage
a little bit of power is to find
communities of like-minded people is to
engage in discourse with them that goes
beyond just you know the the
disagreements that you have across the
whole spectrum arranged you know and
reach some consensus as maybe the
boulder colorado people did and the
Colorado Springs people did and actually
you know push forward and I think that
that's why some of these communities
have a have achieved some power and I
think certainly there's value in the
public sphere in having these broad
perspective and the fact that all these
communities are going on you can just go
look at any of them does allow you to
see a lot more and it's all archived of
the other point of views but there's
also something I think extremely
valuable in the closer ization and I
wondered if you'd speak to that side of
things great and those of us who don't
like like-minded people speaking to one
another have to be enthusiastic about
that question otherwise okay the
opposite point of view there yeah two
points for you too there's there's nice
empirical work supporting exactly what
you say which is if like-minded people
listen to others then they tend to be
less actively engaged in politics so
instead of thinking they might be right
let's go fight for what they want or I'm
right after all but now I appreciate
what they think and appreciating it I'm
all the more willing to be engaged it
tends to have a pacifying effect so
there's evidently a trade-off between
political engagement on the one hand
and which is good and exposure to
diverse perspectives on the other so
this is just you're right that
engagement is often fueled by the social
construction of the boulders and the
Colorado Springs there's an empirical
point on which you are clearly correct
the theoretical point has been
elaborated by a law professor named
Heather gherkin who urges that societies
often benefit from what she calls
second-order diversity not just from
first-order diversity and I think what
you're talking about a second-order
diversity so first order diversity would
say we want let's say every university
in the land to have diversity optimal
diversity that way each person is
exposed to lots of different points of
view or we want every state of the union
to have diversity or every economics
department of diversity diversity within
is first order diversity across the
second order so you might think it's
really good that there's Brigham Young
or the University of Chicago economics
department at the same time that it's
very good that there's Berkeley or the
Harvard very liberal economics
department so liberal being a loyalist
here of Chicago I'm moving to Harvard
there there it's good to have society
benefits from the greater stock of
arguments that is made possible by
polarization so if you have the boulder
people getting all nervous about climate
change and the Colorado Springs people
getting very calm about climate change
you increase the universe of argument
pools from which we might all benefit so
gherkins position is that diversity
across institutions which I would add is
increased by political polarization and
clustering that can be to the benefit of
all of us we get to see a lot of stuff
maybe if this is needs one more example
some empirical work shows that if you
get on the federal courts of appeals
panel is consisting only of Republican
appointees boy do Republic
going to point he's get conservative if
you have courts of appeals three-judge
panels that consists of Democratic
appointees solely Clinton Clinton Carter
the likelihood that a Clinton judge will
vote in a liberal direction jumps a lot
compared to Clinton judge appointees
vote when there's at least one Reagan or
Bush there so the idea would be if we
have a lot of Clinton Clinton Carter
panels and then a lot of Reagan Bush
bush panels we get a big stock of
argument pools in the federal judiciary
from which the Supreme Court maybe or
all of us eventually can benefit there's
a lot of stuff out there so you are
right empirically you get more
engagement if you got clustering and in
principle it might be that the total
stock of arguments increases okay what
the counter concern is that if you get a
really engaged set of inflamed people
who don't understand people who disagree
with them that is at worst little really
literally dangerous at best not
productive of good Democratic
interaction and and the second-order
diversity maybe nothing to celebrate if
you have the the group's who think one
thing unable to engage productively with
the groups who have another thing but
you have a really good point so maybe
that's all I should have said I think
one reason also why you didn't hear it
down here is because I think both cast
and I hold different views of democracy
than the one that is most comfortable
with that polarization which is just
straight pluralism that removes a
substantive element from it removes a
substantive role from public dialogue
and sees it as a competition between
interests if that's your view of
democracy a very pluralistic competition
of of competing views you're fine with
that if you have a view that requires
that has an ambition that is more
substantive be it that there be some
civic virtue and a sense of commitment
to the whole be it that there be some
learning and growth effect of from this
course itself whether or not you have a
commitment to the whole then if you
accept the empirical description of
polarization you have a problem for
either of these positions which I think
are positions that each of us though
different holds about our ambitions for
democracy by comparison to the much
thinner role we give to put that can be
given to politics that accepts without
problem that kind of polarization okay
hello we're getting to there are many
many hands waiting out there so we're
going to shift into what we like to call
the lightning round here which is we're
asking on both sides greater brevity so
that we can get as many questions and as
possible so take it away okay according
to Douglas North the institutions are a
key for economic development and that
helps explain why some countries have
achieved certain levels of economic
development and others not do you see
any link on how this collective
intelligence or collected production
whatever you want to call it can either
influence or change or replace
institutions in developing countries in
short you sent reply i was with you
until you said replace institutions do i
think i spent one chapter in the book
trying to see the degree to which open
collaborative production can improve in
some domains those aspects of
development that defect that depend on
knowledge now that's a lot if you look
at the Human Development Index all of
its components are in some significant
way based on knowledge will eat avoid
famine only if you believe that
Democratic that greater democracy and
greater discourse
where can it improve access to a certain
kind of knowledge-based economy like
free software services industry is
growing in Brazil or being able to
participate in some kinds of open
innovation in principle yes it's not the
whole solution but it can get it can
contribute some high i we heard earlier
on the panel the silly example of
lostpedia and also earlier some of the
acknowledgement that yes fragmentation
can occur where people obsess over
frivolous things and and then but then
conversely that that kind of play can be
used as preparation for other kinds of
more civic engagement so I'm curious if
both panelists see those frivolous or
silly or pop culture activities as
potentially being more than preparatory
play or if there is some value in that
play inherently yeah both really that
the lostpedia is an intrinsic good to
those who really enjoy it and find it
intriguing and fun so those of us who
are mostly concerned about citizenship
shouldn't neglect play especially where
it has a an active rather than passive
feature but also I take what you're
saying on the preparatory side to be
correct and there's some interesting
empirical questions here but a
reasonable thought is that those who
engage their minds actively and things
that are characterized as play may be
better prepared
to be citizens when the time comes well
let me ask a follow up on that question
because I've made the argument in
response to your digital Enclave
argument that in fact that digital
enclaves makes sense if we're talking
about sites define themselves as
partisan to begin with but as we look at
lost or west wing or 24 they would
likely have more ideological diversity
within the core population is it
possible these sites allow more
discussion of across differences because
they're not to find around political
axes to begin with in which case they
might indeed be the beginnings of a more
diverse conversation yeah agreed hi so
Brian liver who is the chief yes hi
Brian vivir who's the achieve technical
officer for Wikimedia once described
Wikipedia by saying it's a site that any
idiot can edit and the big gamble is
there are more good idiots than bad
idiots so in your book infant opioid i
read it as a pretty scathing
condemnation of the ability of the
deliberative majority to arrive at high
quality information consensus how do you
reconcile that with what sounded like
relative optimism about the ability of
wikipedia to enforce like a dignity
standard given that the entire process
in wikipedia is very deliberative and in
fact by largely anonymous group of
people and do you think that the model
will be able to stay the same as
wikipedia grow so do you think that
they'll have to change okay we know that
deliberating groups are subject to for
failures often they amplify rather than
correct individual biases think iraq war
often people are vulnerable to
polarization as discussed a frequently
early speakers will initiate a cascade
in which people don't disclose their
privately held information that's the
third and saddest of all usually shared
information
among a group of three or four people
crowds out uniquely held or unshared
information to the detriment of the
group the advantage of Wikipedia and I
think of the wiki forum generally if the
norms are right but none of those
mistakes will happen partly because the
sheer numbers of people who are involved
in constructing it partly because of the
potential for self correction and partly
because of the individual incentives
which contribute to the problem in the
small deliberating group and work
exactly the opposite way in Wikipedia so
if someone sees there's a mistake in the
description of say Senator McCain they
will benefit in their own mind given
their utility function from correcting
it or they'll be a norm which makes the
utility function very expansive so this
is in an adequate answer but the dynamic
for the wiki is very different from the
dynamic and deliberating groups and
that's the that's the core of the answer
a question getting back I guess to the
ugly side of of what can happen with the
the empowerment that we've been talking
about and and also as yohai mentioned
sort of the the increasing permeability
of the membrane between the net-net
workspace and in real space and I'm
thinking about you know whether we
should be worried about this
amplification effect where a relatively
small group of people wield
disproportionately large amount of
influence that then crosses over into
the real world and when I say this I'm
thinking about this group Anonymous
which I don't know a lot about but Henry
actually hosted an article about this on
his blog recently where I'm assuming
people know what this is but this this
group of of which what i think what i
understand started as kids on the
internet who decided that they want to
take down the Church of Scientology and
use this use this you know our collab
rating and we're talking about this in a
good way but in you know using this for
regardless of what your thoughts are on
the Church of Scientology you know
organizing around denial of service
attacks and you know various sorts of
what I would call undemocratic attacks
against institutions or whatever in the
real world so I guess I'm just wondering
long story short is do we need to do we
need to be worried about that kind of
effect when we talk about the good the
good types of empowerment that we see on
the net well if the if the question of
if the meaning of do we need to be
worried is should we pay attention in
the design of our systems and in
conceiving of what the costs and
benefits of these new platforms is the
answer is yes if the meaning of should
we be worried arm is a is this new
possibility to act maliciously more
scary and more dangerous and ultimately
should cause us to think of this new set
of affordances as a bad thing I'd say
the answer is no I'd say the widespread
this is this is back to the point I was
making about the city earlier there's a
there's a there's a there's a very
similar pattern choose a fear of the
freedom of the net and this is not the
first or second generation of it if I
don't know how many people around here
would remember the 1996 Time magazine
image of the kid in the in the pale blue
watching into the that's been an image
and a fear about the net always and i
think the freedom is the freedom of the
city and the city is not as safe at
least not in our minds when we don't
look what goes on behind closed doors as
the idealized pastor all passed and yet
who among us would give up
the city that's that's my sense of am I
not worried I'm worried I look around
when I walk in the city I do have a very
positive reaction to the question and to
sharpen it may be a little bit there are
blogs or sites power line as an example
which has some very smart conservatives
there I know that power line has said
some very harsh and false things about
people which have permeated the
networked public sphere so much so that
ordinary people who are not necessarily
power line readers not particularly
ideological believe these false things
which are pressed very hard by these
types so that's just one example we're
going to see a lot of them where the
permeability and the network pneus
creates is very destructive to real
people hi so talking about different
views of democracy and this relationship
between the city experience and the web
experience it strikes me that in some
ways these independent websites
especially the interactive ones function
as their own cities with their own rules
of citizenship and I wonder what you
think of of or is it worthwhile to look
at YouTube as its own independent as its
own city to really try and explore what
it means for users to move away from
more vague what how is democracy
changing on the web to really looking
specifically yes and especially if we
have a hypothesis that we're seeking to
test so we might have a hypothesis about
behavior on YouTube and then we have a
place where we can test the hypothesis
my sense is that it would that that it
would be a good and it would be a good
metaphor for some and not so much for
others YouTube is complicated partly
because of the widget aspect and the
fact that it's also distributed partly
because it's it's parallel play it's non
collaborative and it's very it's it's
very broadcast everybody broadcast much
my I can certainly see the analogy being
productive in looking at Wikipedia and
looking at Daily Kos in looking at maybe
clusters of particular blogs but you
know it's a metaphor it's either use
it's not right or wrong it's useful or
or less useful in structuring the the
benefit the way you think about the
risks the benefits the interactions the
the particular cultural clumping and
institutional relations it's sometimes
it's good yeah all right real quick
wanted to ask the question you've talked
about wikis and you've talked about
blogs but with virtual worlds we're now
able to actually see people and of
course it can be recreations that look
like me or can be recreations that look
nothing at all like me and I wonder if
you want to comment on how that's going
to affect sort of citizens entry once
you actually can see other bodies so so
when I get this kind of question I feel
very much like an old fogey because it a
lot of this reminds me of the way people
talked about cyberspace 1012 years ago
you really feel like you're in it it's
all text that said I know that Cory
Andre ker from second life has been
working with in working seriously in
trying to see the degree to which our
visual perceptions affect us emotionally
and psychically in ways that a richly
rendered immersive experience actually
triggers different kinds of responses
and there's some very quirky star
about how people move their bodies more
in response to what they saw in the
mirror than what they are in fact and so
I want to reserve so while I started as
I started I want to reserve judgment the
answer will be in the practice as we see
it whether it be better or worse I
suspect that there will be some things
like for example intends actually it'll
be interesting to see what happens with
with with debate in this regard with the
extent to which facial expressions can
or can't be projected my sense is that
there that the authenticity will be
lacking unless a new set of technologies
and practices of authentication of the
expression work in significantly
interesting ways but that fundamentally
the question is the social interaction
are we consuming together are we
producing together are we collaborative
are we trading that's the important
question and the level of rendering will
end up being less important just one I
just one last quick question on this
very point as you're starting to see
more and more interaction online
actually happening face-to-face via
video is that rather than considering
virtual worlds but actual real world and
real interactions how is that changing
the dynamic of all this I think for
purposes of many of the things we've
discussed it doesn't really matter much
for the Colorado experiment I discussed
which shows the polarization phenomenon
that was all face to face it happens
online essentially in identical forms to
the extent that self sorting creates the
difficulties for mutual understanding
and so forth it's it's basically the
same now there's the anonymity Don
anonymity distinction is a big one the
text I think when you ask you rest in
about second life I wonder for what
purposes would this be different and
purposes of our discussion thus far I
don't see any differences yet the one
thing I'd say from from the work I've
begun to do on collaboration certainly
face-to-face communications or
humanization seem to affect people even
in very thin experimental settings to be
more cooperative and more generous
toward one another the only reason that
I might be wary of moving forward to
thinking that video will be distinctly
different is that you already see a lot
of practices of quite rich rendering and
humanization so if you look at couch
surfing for example where you do need to
give something very up at your door and
there gotta give any violent or not
you're going to be violent or not it's
really interesting so not only do you
see images but you see fairly extensive
descriptions of views and life world and
life views and and so and and Nick and
and the question is whether we've
already between the combi tween static
images and text whether we haven't
gotten to a point where we've gotten
almost all the humanization that we may
or may not at the margin get from
additional video what if you have a
democrat and republican that don't talk
to each other but when they go into this
virtual space I make the Republican look
like Democrat to the Democrat and I make
the Democrat look like the Republican in
a Republican why does the Democrat look
like well no it looks like you have the
reality is I mean their studies that
have shown that if someone looks more
like you you're more likely to trust it
and in a virtual world I can change how
I look to you and you looked me and you
never know it and is that going to
affect how we look because now we can
change how people are mostly make
someone good-looking and and you can
make someone I guess look like you if
you have the technology to do that so
these things would have a fax people
like good-looking people better than bad
looking people i don't know that people
like people who look like them depending
for recruiting right now and so what if
before you went in you said you were
hispanic and so the virtual recruiter is
hispanic recruiter would that make you
more likely to sign up for the US are
probably yeah okay on this note I see
from the clock on the clubhouse wall
that we've exhausted our time I promise
at the beginning that we were going to
have not an internet for it or get it
kind of debate would one that dealt with
a complexity of issues that we're all
observing as we begin to deal with
democracy in the online world and in
that regard I want to thank both
panelists for helping us to see both the
good and the bad the ugly and the
beautiful of the current moment of
digital democracy so thank you very much
the panel and thanks for coming all
you